good morning john it's pizzamas
i have every opportunity to say just
about everything about me on the
internet so i feel like i've said
most of the things but i've searched
around and i don't think i've said this
i like mosh pits or maybe i used to like
mosh fits
i i may have gone in my last mosh pit
like i know that i'm a huge dork and i
wouldn't want anyone to think
anything else but flinging myself into
unknown
turbulent physicality with strangers one
of my top 10 sensations of my life and i
think there are some misconceptions
about them the first being that they are
purely anarchistic and that they are
violent now you can get hurt in the mosh
pit
and there are violent people in mosh
pits but there are also rules now the
rules are going to be different from
scene to scene
like a death metal mosh pit is very
different from a ska punk mosh pit but
anyway as an example the pits i was in
the first and most important rule if
somebody goes down you get them back up
again
however you can because that's the
dangerous moment in a mosh pit when
somebody's on the ground you don't punch
you don't kick like shoving
and pushing are so different from
punching and kicking but i was super
fascinated with when i was a kid though
and this like this era of my life's
maybe from like 15 to 25
is who is making these rules and if you
think about it enough
it becomes this like very clear
microcosm for
how culture works now there are a lot of
inputs here but like in small shows
which was where i was at
like the person in charge is the the
lead singer and if there's like some
some violence happening in the pit they
can either just let it go
or they can say something about it
that's a responsibility that is on them
as a leader in that moment and from
there those cultural norms were then
spread throughout the crowd
and something that had been a
questionable activity beforehand became
something that you obviously shouldn't
do and that the rest of the crowd would
enforce there's a live
seven seconds album called scream reel
out and you can several times throughout
the album hear kevin seconds
say like get that guy out of there or
hey hey hey you need to calm down seven
seconds most wholesome hardcore band
ever
bands of that arrow would also write
songs about the rules
which i it's fascinating to me seven
seconds has a song called not just boys
fun
which is about how to make the hardcore
scene more inclusive
to all genders from 1984 it was 1984 and
the ridiculously influential
kind of overlooked way before its time
banned operation ivy like you listen
their big album
energy like 50 of the songs are either
about how to be a good person generally
like healthy body sick mind
or about how to be a good member of the
gilman street punk scene the crowd is
one of their songs out of the following
line if we're scared of one another must
be scared of ourselves
more than just another crowd we need a
gathering instead
like it's church these people were my
first exposure
to how to intentionally lead a community
now our parents
also were good at that for clarity but
there's a difference between like
a hardcore band and your mom in terms of
like
how cool they are they were leading
their communities they were establishing
norms and they were talking about what
behaviors were and weren't acceptable
the world
looks like chaos and yet usually we're
all able to stay on our feet in the best
situations when we aren't
somebody's there to pick you up because
bad things happen when people are on the
ground and you lift that person back
up not just because that's the rules but
because that
feels so good having someone help you
when you really really need it is nice
and helping someone else when they
really really need it is even better
there's music playing john and it's my
first video of pizzamas
so you know what that means thanks
operation ivy
this ain't no [ __ ] fashion unity
[Music]
see you tomorrow